this side here if you are in this
section of this little section here for
joining a rap the days of the week
what a great [ __ ] suggestion mate
that's just so Sims right under our
noses I like that
cool yeah everyone else [ __ ] hated it
but they're wrong they are you know the
in probably it's Friday night you're
probably like oh I can't sleep big hairy
balls or something
days of the week right so you guys here
what you are at that there were two
pigments of color and fallopian tube we
will take the variation of colors in
fallopian tubes I'm sure I'm sure
they're all different colors are they
cool so probably don't make out like
you've seen them none of you seen
fallopian tubes but dicks so big I
[ __ ] see them all it's it no what
okay so days of the week the variations
of color and fallopian tubes stop
explaining what fallopian tubes are what
guys in the middle what you are rapper
that facial hair cool and check that's
not pointed at me is it I am good bad
paper what would you say is the world's
facial hair a mustache okay cool I mean
you had the goatee to go for you chose
mustache no mustache mustache days of
the week the variations of color in
fallopian tubes guys over here so far
these are some great suggestions so
let's keep it up axolotls ah jesus
[ __ ] christ what's wrong with you why
go with the Australian accent la
asociación triple IE a great time yeah
they are an animal but they're good
because it's quite specific and niche I
feel like that's a fair suggestion it
and the animal rules just stop people
saying dogs and stuff like that if you
don't know what axolotls are they are a
type of kind of permanently juvenile
salamander that lives in a network of
caves only in Central America
specifically I think Mexico and yes [ __ ]
you I know loads about them so
I love it when people try and catch you
out and then you like when I was 13 I
really water max a lot because I didn't
have any friends guys over here what
what brexit stew obviously suggestion
I'm afraid I know it is literally
happening right now like this is the
final day we're gonna finish the show by
holding hands and singing auld lang syne
it's gonna be great
Lord Lucan an astronaut okay Lord Lucan
astronaut yeah oh do you guys know who
Lord Lucan is right well you'll find out
in the rap won't you okay cool so I love
the fact that like 20 of you knew Axl
walls but you're like oh a kind of
British Lord who murdered his wife no
we've never heard of him he is widely
believed to be living in Australia so
Lord Lucan astronaut axolotls bad facial
hair which is mustaches the variations
of color in fallopian tubes and days of
the week those are some baller
suggestions and this is gonna be a
baller freestyle rap there's a rap made
up on the spot bass and Talon those not
written not scripted never be seen again
don't worry it's not gonna be as [ __ ] as
you think it will be let's drop that
beat my friend let's have some fun shows
quite chill Rock so we get too excited
too early in the show
[Music]
a rap has never been seen before my
favorite day of the week is Thursday
because for the North Star is named
after him and I say go back at 8:00
you've gotten old until that's why
Wednesday is felt so strange Monday
named after moon a big range Sunday the
Sun obviously sac yes Saturn the planet
yeah but then fry they happen that's
free of another Norse god of violence
what's the last one here I draw silence
we did all of those yeah up in heaven
it's Norse Valhalla count the days week
that is seven and Wednesday is the hump
tape I can't handle you
I always cross it out there on the
calendar I don't want it
oh I remember Tuesday yeah let me come
and sell for one hand off that's what
the god shoe did people forget about him
I kid you - why are is technically tears
day having lots of fun hold our hands
and sway nobody likes nor scoffs but
that's not that odd and look down in the
kind of female quad stare there and get
my little scalpel and then I insert it
above the genitals and looking to the
side there up here through this is a
speculum right and the uterus and look
to the side and I'm so happy to be
greeted by what transports the egg from
the ovary
that's the fallopian tube and make sure
into the womb it moves you might just
think I thought it all was for joining
us but no it's amazing some of them are
dull and some of them are shininess
some of them I think some of them are
purple some of the dull Brown that's
quite hurtful if you're Colombians who
were so lazy kind of horrible but still
they make babies that's bright that you
push them out from down there when the
baby's born it has no facial hair and if
it did really you would shave its face a
baby with a mustache in that place on
the lip on the palate you say whoa
infant get it off take a little bit
razor in front shave off the lip yeah
get there
I made a baby look like Adolf Hitler why
didn't
have a mustache was it when he was young
maybe probably yeah I feel highly strung
like a lord running from the law where
he's killed a nanny yeah we know about
this you don't understand me Lord Lucan
nah stealin the Luton he ran away on a
train from Luton that's a railway
station near London went off to Cape
Canaveral
Gary thundered right through the doors
said the daddy I just lost her so I need
to sign up here to NASA please take me
into space on the shuttle and really in
trouble because the nanny's in the
puddle of blood and my wife and my son
came home and said why'd you kill the
nanny Lord but I was gone
I ran away I'm not Lord like the kiwi
singer I'm in space now please come try
and bring all of the food and the
nutrients I need to the ISS my horrible
breed led to me to be murdered to be
killed I had the worst Lord since Lord
Damon Hill he was a racing driver I
don't think he was made into a lord
chenna said Lord Adam sugar I would be
adored what was the last one from you
guys in the section spitting back at me
yeah give me that reflection off the
water I see a tiny thing looking like a
snake but it's got some tiny little legs
you know I want to take you from Mexico
there you'll be able to explore and if I
find out I will [ __ ] report you cuz
they're so damn cute I feel quiet you I
feel intelligent that I know these tiny
little newts
some of them are black and some of them
are white they've got great blind vision
in the middle of the night then don't
white fish but they're not like
amphibians yeah look at the low gills
and a little limp they look kind of
red light ate the little quills in the
side of their head why did I like them
so much when I was a smile I really
loved the axolotl here looking at the
child oh they're always bringing in like
Mike Walker so I'm gonna go to Mexico
with the bottle I'm walk-in to the cave
and try and beckon it in and say come on
little Maxim I'll give it a grin and you
can swim right up to me and then I
transport him out of the country
Howard put it in my bum I'd waddle
through security
take it back there I would order it
stare at me a pie on his head and say
you're great and then I'll invite round
the best mate water kebaya thank you
very much for watching please watch more
with playlists spirits subscribe yeah
like comments all those things shouting
bye